hello everybody my name is markiplier
here we go sorry you're going down
you're going down down down down whole
man is hard okay here we go
bunch of all they're down get him all
there down get the knife ha ha oh yes
yes he was he was he was - his broken
nose when he should have been worried
about the knife-wielding maniac come on
down go down
thank you ok ok no sorry sorry sorry
sorry about that
[ __ ] those guys are tough those guys are
really tough those bull was a load of
bull can I have that can I have that I'm
gonna take this I need it for stuff and
things I gotta like expose that guy's
skull that's horrifying guys down ok
down got it
didn't lose a bit of health once on my
mate no you do not
[Applause]
[Music]
oh sorry
uppercut into you into another world
bruh
a world of pain population me I'm the
governor god my pain fliers here ready
for pain okay Oh God
you all right there buddy you need a
hand up Oh your butt got spanked bro
sorry yeah it was a lie I was not sorry
at all Oh give me a bottle give me
something
[Music]
it's not real blood it's blocks red is
the big difference maybe I can just get
in here and start chucking bottles
[Music]
shockwave ready I don't know what that
means
haha Oh God not ha ha ha not Moo ha ha
ha ha ha Oh God
you're like horrible minecraft accidents
bill if you're like if it's your noble
is by the Minecraft village till I hope
this is your balls thanks I don't hope
that it all gross hey what were you
doing friend
punch me in my
oh there's a cool-down for launching
people back I see it okay I got it
these guys are so tough hard it was to
beat someone into submission and by
submission I mean death I guess this is
getting sad now that's right alright
well that's done and I'm almost dead how
am I gonna be able to beat the kitchen
staff with like no health left okay Oh
God
all right in his face broke his bloody
nose oh it's like Jurassic Park all over
again no give me a beer uh-huh okay talk
away ready you ready for this I don't
know Oh God
oh gosh you should have been doing this
from the beginning but there was a lot
of them Oh God Oh laughter me
not fair for us not fair bros Hey
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh that's right you
don't want to fight me
whoa whoa whoa whoa where'd you come
from you don't even have an arm
how are you fighting good god you are
persistent people just learn when to
give up please you guys what you want to
brawl with me bros not I've become
desensitized to violence I'm a maniac
I'm a maniac on the floor I'm a maniac
maniac on the floor literally literally
Barry this is the last one
smite okay I'm gonna save up for smite
because that seems pretty dude yeah zero
zeros nobody putting a whole lot of
nobody you find the wall loser
smite is ready you about to be smited
Bruce get ready
smite so out of a [ __ ] oh oh oh
[Music]
what what oh oh I could keep doing it I
did not know oh my god damn you broke
the beer tap that's amazing
everyone else seems rather calm about
what's happened
I just smited them from the heavens I
might actually be a god okay I'm gonna
use this I'm ease berserk in here here
we go ready beserk time oh this is bad
for you huh boy Oh God Oh
poor guys Oh his face just explodes
boink we need a couple hits don't you oh
you're so tough up not so tough no more
oh no I got the swing freak
damn it sassafras the cooking crew came
out and forced geez
I don't fight fair I literally do
nothing but throw chairs it's the only
way to win the only way to win I'm
completely ludicrous good thing I got
all the training back in my amnesia days
well it's chair throwing paid off
eventually [ __ ] it's time to smite some
[ __ ] you ready for this back down
uh-oh you're gonna die you're gonna die
the old-fashioned way by brewing chairs
ha come at me breath once Samedi not the
one where he's like the boss he's tough
he's the boss he's the boss man he's
divorcing George keep the fourth it's
gonna get eventually there we go
boys okay anyway hey I think this time
for more smiting pink
[Music]
everyone died out terrible oh not you oh
god what was that
hey [ __ ] you god damn it almost
compromising my ideals where's that
boxer all the boxers have the boxer
wants you mano Ichiro sucks for him I
don't fight fair at all ever we I
literally can only run away in throw
things
it's my wanting life is that like Jurgen
from Rocky
his name was definitely Jurgen and
nothing else shut up
just you and me Jurgen did you and me
Jurgen Sturgeon get rekt chit oh he
doesn't fall over oh that's probably a
problem I'm not gonna come all this way
and lose t cold that's right it's time
buddy
wish I'd smite ready oh I gotta watch
that he's gonna get me one Oh baby fight
me on the bar damn he is tough he'd like
Aryan like piece of iron
how's he deal with oh this well went
right through him he's like piece of
iron that knives go through oh no they
slowin down probably the multiple
concussions and extreme brain damage is
slowing him down
oh well oh poor Jurgen he took one too
many chairs to the balls he thinks his
brains are his balls
oh no broke his nose along with
everything else in his face
come on fall over already learn to quit
God you only have one arm last goodbye I
fell over never London I got excited
over I painted the town red I destroyed
everything they spit now there was a ton
of other stuff that I could be used well
I didn't see it so it didn't exist okay
we're done we did it everybody all right
time to punch out and leave time to
punch the clock and get out of here time
to hit the hay Wow I did it okay I guess
it's good goodness they're like more
levels or something that was fun that
was like really fun oh I want to do that
one okay
so thank you everybody so much for
watching this has been paint the town
red thank you for all the suggestions
and thank you jack for suggesting it to
me as well if you want to see more of
this let me know down in the comments
below let me know how well I did in
fighting everybody and thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
do the face i do the face it is